galvanic cells which are also called
voltaic cells use a thermodynamically
favorable reaction to generate an
electric current before we look at a
diagram of a galvanic or voltaic cell
let's first look at the half reactions
that are going to be used in the cell
in the first half reaction zinc metal
loses two electrons to turn into the
zinc two plus cation loss of electrons
is oxidation therefore this is the
oxidation half reaction as a quick
review the other way to tell that this
is the oxidation half reaction is we go
from an oxidation number for solid zinc
of zero to an oxidation number for zinc
two plus of plus two an increase in the
oxidation number is oxidation therefore
zinc metal is oxidized
and here is the other half reaction that
we're going to see in our galvanic cell
diagram in this half reaction the copper
two plus cation gains two electrons to
turn into solid copper
gain of electrons is reduction therefore
this is the reduction half reaction the
other way to tell that this is the
reduction half reaction is to look at
the oxidation numbers so the copper two
plus cation has an oxidation number of
plus two and solid copper has an
oxidation number of zero since there's a
decrease or a reduction in the oxidation
number from plus two to zero
this is the reduction half reaction
a good way to remember which half
reaction is which is to think about leo
the lion goes ger
so loss of electrons is oxidation and
gain of electrons is reduction
when we add the two half reactions
together we have two electrons on the
reactant side and two electrons on the
product side so those cancel out and
that gives us solid zinc plus copper two
plus ions goes to zinc two plus cations
and solid copper
in this redox reaction zinc metal is
oxidized to zinc two plus cations and
copper two plus cations are reduced to
solid copper
delta g naught for this reaction at 25
degrees celsius or room temperature is
less than zero which means this reaction
is thermodynamically favorable
therefore if we were to put a piece of
solid zinc and an aqueous solution of
copper two plus ions
we would see copper metal form on the
zinc metal and zinc two plus ions would
form in solution so that's what would
happen if we did this reaction in only a
single compartment however in a galvanic
or voltaic cell each half reaction gets
its own compartment and the two
compartments are connected with a wire
therefore a thermodynamically favorable
redox reaction is used to generate an
electric current in the wire and by
electric current we're talking about the
flow of electrons now that we've gone
over the half reactions in detail for
this zinc copper galvanic or voltaic
cell let's look at a diagram of this
cell and see how things actually work
let's start by looking at the
compartment on the left which is a
beaker that contains a one molar aqueous
solution of zinc sulfate therefore there
are zinc two plus ions and sulfate
anions in aqueous solution in the beaker
we saw from the oxidation half reaction
that solid zinc is oxidized and turns
into zinc two plus cations when zinc
turns into zinc two plus two electrons
are lost so those electrons will move in
this wire that connects the two
compartments so imagine we have movement
of electrons going from the compartment
on the left towards the compartment on
the right
this piece of solid zinc is called an
electrode the electrode at which
oxidation takes place is called the
anode so let me go ahead and write anode
in here
next let's look at the compartment on
the right which is a beaker that
contains a one molar solution of copper
sulfate so in this beaker there are
copper two plus ions and sulfate anions
in aqueous solution we know that
electrons are moving in this wire that
connects the two compartments at the
surface of this copper electrode
the copper two plus ions come in contact
with two electrons and are reduced to
form solid copper the electrode where
reduction takes place is called the
cathode so the copper electrode is the
cathode for this cell
i went ahead and rewrote each half
reaction to remind us of what's going on
in each compartment so we can think
about what's going to happen to our cell
over time
the anode is where oxidation takes place
so solid zinc turns into zinc two plus
cations so as time goes on
the amount of the solid zinc electrode
will decrease
and the amount of zinc two plus cations
in solution will increase
and the cathode is where reduction takes
place
so as copper two plus cations gain two
electrons to turn into solid copper over
time the amount of copper solid copper
electrode will increase
and the concentration of copper two plus
ions in solution will decrease
a good way to remember that oxidation
occurs at the anode and reduction occurs
at the cathode is to think about two
animals an ox and a cat
so thinking about an ox reminds us that
oxidation occurs at the anode and
thinking about a red cat reminds us that
reduction occurs at the cathode
the next part of the cell that we have
to think about is the salt bridge that
connects these two compartments inside
the salt bridge there's an electrolyte
solution such as sodium nitrate
the electrolyte is often in a gel or
paste form to prevent early mixing with
the other compartments
the solutions in each compartment also
called a half cell must remain
electrically neutral and the purpose of
the salt bridge is to balance the
charges
let's start by thinking about the
compartment or the half cell on the left
when we started we had equal
concentrations of zinc two plus and
sulfate anion so the charges were
balanced however over time the
concentration of zinc two plus ions
increases
to balance out the increased positive
charge the negatively charged anion in
this case the nitrate anion moves from
the salt bridge into the half cell on
the left
next let's think about the compartment
or the half cell on the right
we started off with equal concentrations
of copper two plus cation and sulfate
anion however over time there's a
decrease in copper two plus cation
therefore there's too much negative
charge in this half cell to balance out
the negatively charged sulfate anions
the positively charged ion and the salt
bridge in this case the sodium cation
moves from the salt bridge into the half
cell on the right
a good way to remember which direction
the ions go in the salt bridge is to
think about anions going toward the
anode and cations going toward the
cathode
the salt bridge is necessary for the
galvanic cell to work if the salt bridge
were removed the electrons would stop
moving in the wire and that brings us to
the last component of our galvanic cell
which is this volt meter here for this
particular galvanic cell with one molar
concentration of zinc sulfate one molar
concentration of copper sulfate at 25
degrees celsius the initial voltage
would be 1.10 volts so that's what would
show up on the voltmeter the voltmeter
measures the difference in electric
potential between two points and as long
as there's a difference in electric
potential electrons will flow in the
wire however this thermodynamically
favorable redox reaction doesn't last
forever eventually the reaction reaches
equilibrium and at that point the
voltage is equal to zero
and when the voltage goes to zero the
current also goes to zero which means
the electrons are no longer moving in
the wire
you could also call a galvanic or
voltaic cell a battery so at that point
the battery is dead
let's do a quick summary of galvanic or
voltaic cells these cells use a
thermodynamically favored redox reaction
this redox reaction generates an
electric current that flows in the wire
between the two electrodes the electrode
where oxidation takes place is called
the anode and the electrode where
reduction takes place is called the
cathode a salt bridge is used to balance
the charges in the two compartments
eventually the reaction reaches
equilibrium and at equilibrium the
voltage is equal to zero which means
there's no more current and the galvanic
or voltaic cell stops working